la comisión que presidía había predicho
exactamente esto que tendríamos un
ataque masivo y mortífero en territorio
estadounidense y que deberíamos cambiar
nuestras políticas
esta mañana iba en un avión de
washington a nueva york
el piloto vino a verme para decirme que
un avión había chocado contra el world
trade center y que por eso debíamos dar
vueltas alrededor de filadelfia donde
estábamos en la elegancia
y llamé en esos días unos llamaba desde
el avión llamé a mi secretaria en nueva
york y me dijo dios mío otro avión chocó
contra el world trade center
the women's entonces ahí dije había una
mujer sentada a mi lado dije esto es un
ataque terrorista hoy no vamos a llegar
a nueva york claro que no pudimos fuimos
obligados a aterrizar de inmediato en
baltimore hay cadena taxi donde tomé un
taxi para que me llevará de vuelta a
maryland a washington
y una gran tristeza porque acababa de
ser nombrado presidente de la comisión
nacional sobre el terrorismo en 1999
por un grupo bipartidista y le habíamos
reportado tanto el presidente clinton y
luego el presidente bush que el tipo de
terrorismo contra el que habíamos
luchado en los 80 había cambiado durante
los 90 y que no estábamos nuestro
gobierno preparados para enfrentar esta
nueva forma de terrorismo
y muy a mi pesar ni la administración
clinton ni la de bus pusieron atención a
nuestro informe que entregamos cerca de
un año y medio antes del 11 de
septiembre
para mí fue algo muy difícil porque la
comisión que presidía había predicho
exactamente esto que tendríamos un
ataque masivo y mortífero en territorio
estadounidense y que debíamos cambiar
nuestras políticas
twiter para oasis
y
eso nos llevó al colapso del gobierno no
es cierto eso no era un gobierno eficaz
porque
no había computadores el único
ministerio que tenía algún computador
era el de planeación no había una red
telefónica nacional y no se podía llamar
a menos de que fuera miembro de la
guardia revolucionaria y se llamara a
mosúl y basora
no había tampoco cómo transportar dinero
de un lugar a otro a menos de que fuera
cargado un camión con dinares con dinero
físico antiguo track
entonces no era un gobierno eficiente y
la gente los reporteros que afirman que
haber sacado el partido a se hizo
colapsar al gobierno se equivocan no
creo que ninguno de ellos haya visitado
algún ministerio yo estuve en todos y
como trabajaban
y
el error que cometí fue no emitir emitir
el decreto era lo que se debía hacer
el error que cometí fue entregar a los
políticos iraquíes
la implementación de un decreto muy
limitado seis meses después hacia
noviembre de 2003
ese fue el error porque entonces los
iraquíes trataron de usarlo para
vengarse sabe bueno puede que éste no
sea de elvas pero quizás sí deshagámonos
de él la gente fue perdiendo sus
trabajos y yo tenía que tratar de darle
reversa a eso
mientras
los servicios de inteligencia se
equivocaron nunca se hallaron armas de
destrucción masiva mientras yo estuve
allí y desde entonces tampoco
uno puede entrar a especular qué fue lo
que salió mal no lo sé no soy un experto
en inteligencia
creo que la única cosa que puedo decir
al respecto es que fue algo coherente
cuando el presidente bush dijo que había
que confiar en los servicios de
inteligencia
y ellos nos dicen que ese material está
y que hay que tomar cartas en el asunto
fue una falta de inteligencia quiero
decir que eso sucede en una guerra de
sap en sen wars